hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt ein kleines rezept zum
valentinstag und zwar habe ich dieses
schießen valentinstags monster gebacken
und zwar steckt da jeweils ein muffin
drunter und zwar einmal ein schoko
muffins und dann habe ich da so eine
erdbeer creme und einmal ein heller
muffin der rot gefärbt ist mit after
eight genau mit minze und wie man dieser
süßen leckeren valentinstags muffins
packt zeig ich euch jetzt und sei durch
eine schnell die zutaten für die muffins
ich mache jetzt zur firma finn type und
zwar ist mein basis rezept für muffins
aber ich zeige euch die zutaten jetzt
trotzdem kurz denn ich nehme das basis
rezept und halbiert es dann und dann
mache ich die hälfte als schoko
geschmack also mit kakaopulver die
hälfte mache ich hell und färbt sie
daneben 1
und ja ich sage euch kurz die zutaten
zum fetten der backform brauche ich
etwas back trance prey und für den teig
bis 150 gramm weiche butter 150 g zucker
1 prise salz etwas vanille extrakt
zweier ich habe ich 160 gramm mehl dann
habe ich noch einmal 30 gramm mehl und
30 gramm kakaopulver und hier habe ich
noch einen halben teelöffel backpulver
im viertel teelöffel natron und etwas
milch und zum färben braucht mich
lebensmittel verpasste zuerst hätte ich
jetzt die backform ein und zwar brauche
ich dieses mal die muffins nicht in
einer papierform
denn es kommt ja außenrum später diese
creme und deswegen wäre es einfach eine
verschwendung wenn jetzt papier formen
nimmt und die dann später wieder ab
machen muss deswegen ist es einfacher
die form einfach ein zu retten
dann kann ich den teig herstellen den
ofen habe ich übrigens auch bereits
schon vorgeheizt dann gebe ich jetzt die
weitere mutter in meine rührschüssel und
übrigens jetzt auch alle zutaten zimmer
waren
das sollte auch so sein ansonsten wird
das leben nicht schön homogenen gebe ich
da noch den zucker mit rein und das als
und auch etwas vanille extrakt dazu ein
paar tropfen
und jetzt kann ich das erst mal 34
minuten lang cremig rühren
jetzt kommen noch die zwei eier mit dazu
und die röhre ich jetzt auch ganz kurz
nur ein so etwa eine minute trocken
taten also die große portion mehl mit
backpulver natron und zwar mache ich das
jetzt um jetzt erstmal diesen basis
herzustellen
und wenn ihr zb jetzt kein natron habt
könnt ihr auch einfach nur backpulver
benutzen aber mit natron geht es eben
noch mal besser auf gebe ich das alles
hier rein und dann noch ein schluck
milch und da mache ich jetzt so meinel
extrakt besitzt nämlich leer und damit
ich da jetzt alles noch gut raus bekomme
will ich da immer so ein bisschen milch
rhein mit einem trichter zum beispiel
und dann kann ich eben das ganze
vanillemark dabei raus bekommen
ansonsten müssen wir sehr wegschmeißen
und können es nicht aus der flasche
bekommen und es können mit jeder
flüssigkeit machen als ich finde es hier
ein nicht sehr sinnvoll dann einfach
schütteln und so bekommt man schön alles
raus jetzt gebe ich das hier mit rein
ich kann dann die leere flasche einfach
wegschmeißen
jetzt das ganz kurz ein
mit sieht man auch hier ganz deutlich
dieses vanillemark und es ist echt ganz
toll und schmeckt wirklich hervorragend
den teig den halb ihr ich jetzt also ich
nehme die hälfte jetzt heraus und zwar
markiere ich da einfach die hälfte nimmt
hier raus und dann kann ich eben die
eine hälfte mit schoko einfärben also
mit kakaopulver und die andere hälfte
mit der lebensmittelfarbe mache ich das
eine hier drin
hier gebe ich jetzt schon rein also
etwas milch und stand kakaopulver und
lasst es kurz verrühren
und in die andere hälfte also hier gebe
ich mir ein
und auch etwas milch damit die
konsistenz gleich ist und da gebe ich
jetzt noch etwas rot mit rein ist es
einfach kurzem teig schafe oder mit
einem schneebesen durch
der rote teig des aids geschmacksneutral
man könnte jetzt hier natürlich auch
aromen hinzufügen zb zitronenschale oder
andere schöne aromen aber ich lasse es
jetzt neutral denn die creme später
schmeckt ja dann nach pfefferminze und
deswegen möchte ich hier einen neutralen
teig und die farbe das ist übrigens
immer noch die gleiche fahrweise ich bin
uns immer auf die kovac farben macht
sich da die verpackung geändert und ist
jetzt schön pink weil mich neulich neben
welche danach gefragt hatten
und es sind übrigens immer noch diese
art zu freien farben also die einzigen
die es eigentlich er momentan auch im
handel gibt ab zu frei und farben sind
übrigens in griechenland und murat in
dänemark geld komplett verboten und bei
uns verschwinden sie auch nach und nach
aus dem handel und das finde ich auch
recht gut so so jetzt nämlich ein eis
portionierer und stellt jetzt hier den
teig ab und gebt denen dann hier in die
muffins
so habe ich schöne gleich große
portionen
die muffins werden jetzt im vorgeheizten
backofen bei 170 grad ober unterhitze
für 20 minuten gebacken und nach der
backzeit las ich zuerst komplett
abkühlen
die muffins sind jetzt komplett
abgekühlt und jetzt muss ich noch die
creme herstellen
für die creme habe ich hier vorne die
zutaten und zwar brauche ich 200 g
weiche butter 200 gramm puderzucker und
zwar hatte ich kein puderzucker mehr und
habt den normalen haushaltszucker
einfach in magnetic drive blender
pulverisiert und habe es butter zucker
dann habe ich hier 200 gramm frischkäse
philadelphia und die habe ich noch zwei
male sirup und zwei helfer minze und
here at wäre dann brauche ich noch
lebensmittel farben rosa grün und blau
können natürlich nach belieben einfärben
einfachzucker augen
hier habe ich noch modelle schokolade in
rot und pop sticks jetzt stelle ich
zuerst mal die creme her gibt es die
weiche butter in eine schüssel
da kommt jetzt der puderzucker mit dazu
das war schon wahnsinn geht es eben
pulverisiert wurde das verriet jetzt
kurz es geht so etwa eine minute
wenn die mutter dann weiß cremig es gebe
ich den frischkäse mit rein und da wird
jetzt nur noch kurz untergerührt
es gebe ich die hälfte der gremien eine
zweite schüssel und zwar muss ich die
kremitz ersten einfärben
zur einen hälfte gebe ich jetzt etwas
erdbeer sirup rein einfach für den
geschmack und g pro seine lebensmittel
verpasste mit rein
und hier kommt jetzt etwas pfefferminze
rhein und die fertig dann mit etwas blau
und grün und die cremes müssen dann noch
mal ganz kurz für etwa fünf bis zehn
minuten in den kühlschrank denn
ansonsten sind sie etwas zu weich um sie
auf die muffins darauf zu stützen
die zwischenzeit kann ich jetzt schon
mal nutzen und die muffins vorbereiten
und zwar sind die ja etwas flach und
also etwas bleibt nicht flach und ich
möchte jetzt aber gerne etwas rundliche
haben und deswegen habe ich jetzt ein
ausstecher der hat so etwa 4 cm im
durchmesser und man sieht jetzt auch
ganz gut dass wenn ich das jetzt hier
ausstecher habe ich da oben noch diese
hunde und dann habe ich so eine schöne
kugeln das heißt ich stecke jetzt hier
aus wenn wir diesen ausstecher nicht hat
kann man ein glas nehmen und das ganze
mit messer zum beispiel schneiden und
ursprünglich hatte ich überlegt mini
muffins zu machen
aber die werden wir dann zu klein
gewesen
und damit die muffins nicht brechen ist
es auch besser wenn ihr erst mit dem
messer ein rest und dann aussticht
sonst kann es nämlich so wie hier
passieren dass die oberfläche ist ein
bisschen reist und das wollen will ich
mein glas kann man das auch machen wir
ja mit schneiden dann
die rote modelle schokolade habe ich
jetzt schon mal weich geknetet und
rollte jetzt dünn aus
und da stecke ich jetzt mit einem herz
des ungefähr so groß ist wie der muffin
herzchen los und zwar braucht der pro
muffin ein herz
die creme fühle ich jetzt in einen
spritzbeutel und da habe ich jetzt eine
graf kühle vorne drauf dass bei sich
eine kleine täler und da habe ich auch
noch einen kleinen adapter brand und
jetzt ist es so richtig streichfähig und
nicht zu weich und ich kann sie deswegen
dann auch gleich gut spritzen
jetzt habe ich hier so ein kleines
säckchen das setzt sich jetzt immer die
muffins einzelnen drauf sehe mich zuerst
so ein herz ist nämlich die füße legen
genau die roten mache ich dann mit
dieser grünen creme jetzt plötzlich trat
ein bisschen creme da drauf damit der
macht ihn gut kleben bleibt
jetzt muss der kunden das vorne eben die
füße dann auch bisschen rausschaut und
zwar ein bisschen mehr denn gleich von
der creme wird ja auch ein bisschen was
verdeckt und damit das arbeiten jetzt
einfacher geht bestreite ich den muffin
einer komplett ganz dünn mit der creme
so sind nämlich die krümel dann gebunden
dann können wir den gleich besser
bespritzen
jetzt beginne ich mit dem spritzen unten
und arbeite mich nach oben
jetzt nimmt der entweder die cake pops
ticks vorbei die mir jetzt zu lange sind
ich nehme zahnstocher und klebt das herz
dran und zwar mit etwas zucker kleber
vor dem zahnstocher rein mit dem zweiten
herz zu klappen
und die zwei könnte dann nach oben rein
stechen ein kleines monster
jetzt stelle ich die kleinen man schon
in den kühlschrank und macht noch die
anderen fertig
die muffins sind jetzt fertig und ich
finds echt süß und ich habs jetzt beim
zubereiten so gemacht dass ich immer
einen grünen gemacht habe dann einen
rosa und in der zeit an den anderen
spritzbeutel wieder im kühlschrank
gegeben habe denn wenn man den sprit
ball in der hand hat wird die creme
weichen und kann man diese süße gras
optik wurde diese fälle ob es sage ich
jetzt mal nicht so schön spritzen
deswegen sollte die creme immer schön
kühl sein und ja ich weiß dann ob jetzt
ein probieren mit murat sagen du
zerstörst du jetzt merkt ja sowie süßes
gegessen mich noch weiter süße dann dann
tut man beim blut irgendwie zusammen
frieren erscheinung zu gehör ist ja
deswegen wir lassen den hübsch und ich
mache jetzt gleich noch die fotos für
meinen blog ihr könnt das rezept
natürlich wie immer nachlesen auf salehs
blog.de
und ja ich freue mich wenn jetzt nach
macht und wenn ich euch da eine anregung
geben konnte
als bis zum nächsten mal tschüss und
kocht was deftiges zu sagen ja ich hab
jetzt irgendwie süß rezepte das gibt es
halt dann zum nachtisch ist als vorher
was mir das kochen